the p47d 4 variants and onwards were
fitted with a 30-gallon tank filled with
an alcohol water mixture located between
the pilot and the engine in the firewall
water injection increases horsepower in
two ways both as a result of water's
cooling effects when water is injected
into the engine it absorbs heat from the
air and engine in the process of
evaporating this increases engine
pressure and lowers the temperature of
the Piston C older air is denser and
thus more air fuel mixture is carried
into the Piston with each stroke
increasing the energy released in each
Power Stroke the evaporation also cools
hotpots in the engine that can cause
pre-ignition of the air fuel mixture
meaning the air fuel mixture ignites
before the Piston is at the bottom of
its compression stroke and thus is
working against the power strokes in the
other cylinders lowering the power
output of the engine